(hip hop beat)
- Good morning.
What's up guys, ya'll good?
What you doin' dog?
- Just trying to get these rhymes tight.
- Let me check this junk out, man.
We gotta record this.
Immediately.
- I agree.
- Make some money on that
mix tape circuit, yo.
(DJ scratching)
(hip hop beat)
- Double Trouble.
- Oh man.
- This shit bout to
drop, its goin' be dope.
It's goin' be ill, yo.
(laughs)
(hip hop beat)
- Yo, what's good man?
Can I take a moment of your time?
We're selling these CDs.
- Yeah what's up.
- Get a listen to it real quick.
- [Keith] This new mix tape, it's hot.
- It's fire man.
- ♫ Stupid ass hat makin' big homie mad
♫ Stupid lame hat goin' get you stabbed
♫ That's right,
- What?
- ♫ the person right in front of me
♫ Wearin' that hat, I'm talkin' bout you
- What, are you trying to
go some place with this?
- We're going straight to the top.
- Get the (bleep)
- Hey holla
Alright, we're Double Trouble.
We're comin' out with this new mix tape
called "Double Impact."
- [Keith] Absolutely.
- We wanted to know if you
wanted to have a listen.
- Sure.
(slow rap beat)
♫ Cause I'm goin' doo-doo in your mouth
♫ and pee-pee in your face
♫ I'm goin' doo-doo in your mouth
- It's really good.
♫ Then kill the right race
♫ Every last one of 'em
♫ I don't like none of 'em
♫ I hate 'em all
♫ I hate white people
♫ I hate you specifically
♫ Standing in front of me
♫ We goin' kill you first
- Yeah, it was really good.
- You like it?
That was hot, wasn't it?
- It's fun.
- That's harsh. (laughs)
- What was your favorite line in the song?
- Probably I hate white people.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- See?
Nobody likes white people.
♫ Got a lot of bags
♫ I hope you enjoyed shopping,
'cause its gonna be your last
♫ Big homie bout to kill yo ass
♫ He right behind you, he don't like you
♫ He goin' kill you
♫ Cause you got a lot of shoppin' bags
- Big homie hates bags.
- (bleep) bags.
- I've also got a paper bag.
- No, all bags man.
- All bags?
- Yeah, everyone of 'em.
- It's about the environment, man.
You don't care about the environment?
♫ White dudes don't know shit about shit
- I think I, as a white
guy, I think I know
some things, you know? Some shit.
♫ I'm the most violent dude
on this street right here
♫ I just kill people right here
♫ I killed a person yesterday,
right here, for no reason
♫ I just kill people on this street
♫ Listenin' to my mix tape
♫ I just be killin' people
♫ I don't like when they
listen to my mix tape
♫ I just kill 'em
- How many you want?
How many CDs you want for this. Man?
You want three?
(hip hop drum beat)
(stomach growling)